For what value of c is x minus
3 a factor of the polynomial p
of x?
And they tell us that p of x is
negative x to the third power,
plus cx squared,
minus 4x, plus 3.
So I encourage you to
now pause this video
and try to figure
this out on your own.
So the remainder theorem
tells us that if x minus 3
is a factor of p of x.
Now that's another way
of saying that p of x
could be written as x minus
3, times something else.
This is true if and only
if p of 3 is equal to 0.
p of three-- I would write
p in that yellow color--
This is true if and only
if p of 3 is equal to 0.
And this makes complete sense.
Because if you put 3--
if you evaluate p of 3,
we're saying that x minus
3 is a factor of p of x.
That means that you could
write p of x like this.
So, if you could write p of x
like this, what would p of 3
be?
You substitute a
3 right over here,
you're going to have 3
minus 3 for this expression.
That's just going to be
0 times something else.
Anything times 0 is 0.
So this should make just
a lot of common sense.
So p of 3 needs
to be equal to 0.
So let's just evaluate p
of 3 and then figure out
what c needs to be in order
to make p of 3 equal to 0.
So let's write this down.
So p of-- I'll do the
three in green-- p of 3
is going to be equal
to negative 3--
wrote it all in one
color, actually--
3 to the third power, plus c
times 3 squared, minus 4 times
3, plus 3.
So what's this going
to be equal to?
This is going to be equal
to negative 27, plus 9
c, minus 12, plus 3.
So what does that equal to?
This is negative 12 plus 3 is
negative 9, plus negative 27
is negative 36 so this is
going to be 9 c minus 36.
And remember, we want p
of 3 to be equal to 0.
This is p of 3, so we want
this thing right over here
to be equal to 0.
So I'm going to make this clear.
We have p of 3 is
equal to this, and we
want to set this
to be equal to 0.
So let's just solve this
equation right over here.
So you add 36 to both sides,
you get 9 c is equal to 36.
divide both sides by 9,
you get c is equal to 4.
So if c is equal to
4, if p of x were
to be equal to negative
x to the third,
plus 4x squared, minus
4x, plus 3, then x minus 3
is a factor of p of x.